if you happen to be in Callwood today
you might have noticed some excitement
and a lot of extra security around Royal
Roads University a film crew has taken
over the iconic Hatley Castle the lights
are up cameras rolling but exactly what
they're shooting is still a bit of a
mystery the University and the South
Island Film Commission will only confirm
there is a production filming at the
castle the film's publicist says it's a
movie called Love Machine but an online
search shows that's the working title
for the sequel to last year's hugely
popular Deadpool we're just visiting I
got some friends from Sherbrooke Quebec
that came down so we wanted to show them
Hadley castle oh we weren't able to get
too close but yeah we were able to check
out the outside and they're pretty happy
about seeing the castle but the plots on
the stairs every floor system
unfortunately not our floors so they did
that and I know they've added extra
flowers to circles in the front and
people always get very excited about it
when it's always fun laser it goes to
these films and then you consider
pinpoint where it was today was the only
day of filming schedule for Hadley
Castle the rest of the Deadpool sequel
is being shot in Vancouver the first
movie made nearly 800 million dollars at
the box office
Deadpool 2 hits theaters June 1st of
next year
everybody whole bunch of Deadpool just
dropped we also know some more about the
characters so let's break it down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's
going to be Deadpool happening all
summer this is just the start of filming
they said that they were on set for
about a day so that makes it sound like
they're going to have a scene just like
in the first dead pool movie where he
walks up to the front door asked for
their help and then they come out and
help him with whatever mission he's on
so we'll talk about the story in a
second because based on the characters
that they're casting it sounds like an
amalgam of different stories there'll be
a lot of Deadpool on cable New Mutants
98 the energy from their first meeting
together was not very friendly Deadpool
was sent to assassinate him by Tolliver
they fought each other then with the
help of surprise surprise Domino
Deadpool is neutralized so what a
coincidences they just cast Ozzy beats
as Domino this could be one of the ways
they introduce her in the movie you
called I came then they bumped heads
against each other throughout x-force
eventually they got their own title
together cable and Deadpool where they
worked together but it was still a
really contentious relationship Deadpool
was the funny man cable was the straight
man who would just keep getting pissed
off with all his jokes only Ryan
Reynolds posted this picture so that
means that Josh Brolin wasn't on set so
it's probably just them filming the
exterior with a couple of the x-men
characters like negasonic teenage
warhead
maybe Colossus they're both coming back
but the new big characters you've been
hearing about are Domino Jack Cassey
who's playing the villain who I think
might be black Tom Cassidy I'll talk
about him in a second and then they just
cast a new Asian actress named Sheila
kutsuna who made you know outside chance
pie-in-the-sky be playing Lady
Deathstrike because she had a big role
during Messiah Complex in that Deadpool
teaser when it was teasing Nathan
summers also teased hope even though I'm
not expecting hope to be in the movie
it's just one of the big stories that
involves Lady Deathstrike Cable Deadpool
Domino goes back even further to classic
ex for stuff so if you wanna read the
comics to get ready for the movie I
would recommend checking out Messiah
Complex the original cable and Deadpool
run and then sort of their initial
meeting through New Mutants and x-force
we don't know a whole lot about what's
going on with the x-force movie because
they're making new mutants
right now which as far as I know is not
connected to Deadpool but it shares a
little bit in common it's sort of off by
itself it's not part of the main x-men
films it's not really part of Deadpool
it'll probably reference the other
movies the way that Deadpool references
the other movies so I think they're just
trying to see how everything works out
before they all throw it together and a
big team up movie the really cool thing
about x-force though is that they've
confirmed they cable and Deadpool are
going to be lead characters in that they
made Josh Brolin sign a five picture
contract when you signed on to be cable
so obviously that's this movie that's
exports the third Deadpool movie
probably an x-force sequel and then
anywhere else they want to stick them
they can stick them in the main x-men
film since they want but I'm not
expecting it because I think they want
to keep him relatively r-rated one of
the big reasons why people think that
black Tom is the villain of Deadpool too
is is because cable was sent to kill him
while Deadpool was hired by Toliver to
protect him so it's a way for them to
butt heads black Tom gets injured as
he's being healed he gets turned into a
mutant so he has plant-based powers he
has regeneration you can cut his limbs
off like you cut Deadpool's limbs off he
has a lot of Deadpool like powers that's
when he starts being a crazy villain and
he's the brother of Sean Cassidy who
died during the earlier x-men films so
there's a lot of crossover points in the
new Asian actress the reason people
think that she might be Lady Deathstrike
one because she's a really cool
character but two because during Messiah
Complex she was tracking down hope and
cable trying to kill them with the help
of the Reapers which were just used in
the Logan movie which is another big
point of crossover so there's just a lot
of opportunities for Deadpool to
continue making fun of the other x-men
films in the messed-up timeline but as
far as we know this movie picks up just
a little while after the first movie
it's not going to be like the main x-men
films where you're jumping decade to
decade so x-men Days of Future past in
the 70s x-men apocalypse in the 80s and
now x-men Dark Phoenix said in the early
90s
Deadpool came out February 2016 Deadpool
2 is going to come out summer 2018 so
just assume that it's about a year and a
half inside the timeline of the movie -
so he's gone back to contract killing
with the help of weasel he's back with
Vanessa who he's
rescued blind owl is coming back to so
I'm assuming he's not living with her or
if they want to be really awkward about
it they could have them both living with
blind al and I appreciate the gesture
come on crazy but is your hand really
small about the size of the KFC spork
but it's for domino they go all the way
back to six-pack so I'm expecting the
dough just cross paths when they're out
killing people like Deadpool be out on
contracts and they'll just bump into
each other but they'll have a reason to
team up because of what cable is doing
because of what the villain is doing so
what you'll probably see in the next
couple months as you'll see josh brolin
rolling around on set in vancouver
though filming it in relatively the same
area where they filmed the first
Deadpool movie because Deadpool has gone
back to his old life so you see a lot of
familiar locations but because they
won't be done in time for Comic Con they
might not have a full trailer but they
will have something to show off so
they'll have some funny clip like they
did before the Logan movie like hey this
isn't an official trailer but this is
the Deadpool 2 trailer that you've been
waiting for a trailer for a movie that
hasn't even been made yet so let me know
they come to comic-con they don't have a
trailer ready what do you want them to
do just something funny like this or do
you just wanted to pull some crazy stunt
the only thing that I'm not expecting is
them to bring a whole bunch of Dark
Phoenix stuff just because of the cloud
that's sort of over that franchise I
think they want people to forget about
it for a little while till they film it
and they make sure that it's ready for
eyeballs then they'll show it to people
like hey look here's something we made
is really cool x-men can be cool again
but it's a lot harder to do when you
show people unfinished footage like
people were really down on a Wonder
Woman when they saw the first trailers
but everybody went crazy after they saw
the movie so just remember the early
stuff you see is going to be way
different when you're watching it on a
big movie screen
we'll leave all your requests for
Deadpool videos in the comments below
there'll be a lot more Deadpool later
this summer especially as they start
rolling footage out but I got some new
arrow season 6 I got some new Rick and
Morty Game of Thrones so I'll post that
as fast as possible while you wait for
everything you can click here to watch
the Deadpool bloopers again and you can
click here for brand new flash thanks
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you